Hello everybody. Hope that you're good.
Today it's an important day because the
markets are going to be reacting to the
US and Venezuela conflict that happened
on Saturday. Yes, Saturday again. And it
seems some kind of norm because if
you've noticed the past conflicts always
happened on Saturdays. Iran Israel
conflict happened on Saturday. US and
Venezuela conflict happened on a
Saturday. And my logic tells me that is
because they don't want to dump their
own stock markets. So what they do
instead is that they do on Saturdays. So
they have more time until Monday to
reduce the uncertainty of what is going
to happen. Is there going to be
escalation,
you know, or what is the other the other
side going to say about it? So they kind
of give themselves a couple of days to
reduce the uncertainty and to increase a
bit of the clarity of what it's going
on. And as I said on on X, I think
pretty it pretty much all depended on if
Russia or China were going to respond
publicly with some kind of public
statement. Um, as far as I'm concerned,
they didn't. So it seems like nothing's
happening. It seems that the market knew
that the conflict between US and
Venezuela was a problem and it was going
to break out at any moment and it could
have got ugly. You know, the market was
kind of scared about what it could
potentially happen in Venezuela, you
know, like uh maybe a proper invasion
with tanks,
bombs destroying the city. Who knows?
There was uncertainty and in fact it's
been quite clean. You know, they went
there. It's true that they threw a few
bombs to some military bases and and
stuff, but they got the guy out, the
president, they kidnapped him, they got
him out, and it's been quite clean. So,
the market is like, okay, that that
conflict that was going to happen, it
seems like it's not going to get that
ugly. Russian, China are not saying
anything. There are no tanks in
Venezuela. So
there's a bit of I would say
geopolitical clarity in this aspect
which sounds uh controversial but that's
pretty much it. And he explains why the
S&P today is open positively. Look how
it's going up. Okay, look how it's going
up since he opened. This is the futures
and now it's opening and it's moving up.
Okay, because there is your political
clarity. Now, if you go to Bitcoin,
you're going to see Bitcoin also
reacting to it. Not to the Venezuela and
US conflict because that already did
over the weekend, but it's reacting to
the US market not dumping. Okay? So, you
can see here if we put the daily time
frame, you can see that today is already
going up 2%. All right? It already broke
above the daily 50 MA. That that could
have been a resistance.
All right? quite a minor resistance to
be honest because it hasn't been tested
for ages. So we knew that it was not
going to be much of a fight there. But
if you notice now you have here a 94,000
a local resistance and a 100k the high
time frame resistance psychological
level and also you have the weekly 50 in
between and 98k right so what is going
to happen in bitcoin
I don't know but I can tell you how I'm
going to trade it how I'm preparing
myself to trade this week as I said it
here at the middle of the range I'm not
interested in taking a position I didn't
take any because price could have gone
up the same as it could have gone down.
No reason to trade at the mid-range. I'm
looking to trade deviations or
breakouts. So, I would say that we have
a range between 94K
very clearly and you could put your
range lows either 80K or really here
also 84K. You can see that this is a
very tight range. Okay. So, different
ways to trade this. Let me explain to
you my ideas. The first thing if we see
a breakout past the local resistance
that would mean that price would need to
break above 94,300
tested a support that's what I will be
opening my long towards two levels the
weekly 50 MA and the high time frame
resistance. How would I trade this? Well
the first moment that I enter my long
here I'm setting up already my take
profits. I would set up 66% of my take
profits at the weekly 50 MA and the 33%
remaining at the high time frame
resistance because it's possible the
price could drop from the weekly 50 MA
and I wouldn't otherwise take any
profits. So the way that I'm trading
this is as long as this retest happens
I'm opening a long if price starts to go
up a stop-loss uh break even. Okay. and
66% of profits at the weekly 50 main and
the other third at the high time frame
resistance. Okay. Now, if price starts
to turn around here,
then it'll hit my stop loss and then I
will open a short towards this area
between 84K and 80K. Okay? And I
wouldn't open a long again until I see a
deviation below 80K.
All right? So that will be around n 79k
give or take. That is my plan. Simple.
Keep it simple. That is my model super
Andi. Uh if you keep it simple, I know
exactly where I want to make some
business. And if I keep it simple, then
I know that my strategies are always
going to be the same. All right? So that
is the way that I'm um trading for this
week. Now, if price starts to, and I'll
repeat it again, I do not think that
price is going to recover like this to
alltime highs, I don't think so. I do
think that if it goes up, that could be
a room for liquidity. Could be towards
the weekly 50, maybe a bit higher, but
that would be me pushing a bit too much.
Say the weekly 50. Okay, that would be a
room for liquidity.
And then price more likely would go
again to these lows where it could you
know find some support either a sweep of
the lows here or some more base uh
bottom base formation here and then
price could go up. I don't see price
going up in a straight line up from
here. That is my take. Again it's my
opinion just so you can criticize it but
that is my take. Okay. I do think that
price is likely to do if he continues
going higher past the local resistance.
Okay, because it's through the local
resistance, it could turn around. But if
he goes above the local resistance, I do
think that the upside is quite limited
towards this area here. That will be a
room for liquidity and then price could
drop again before going higher. That is
my take. We saw this also
in October 2019. Let's go back really
quickly. I went back in the in the last
video I showed you and also in the in
the sun update, but you can see the same
here. Price drops very fast. That's
what's happened. You have a tight range
deviation above the top of the range.
That's a liquidity run because it's
trapping traders and it's hitting short
stop losses and liquidations.
Then you see that soup of the lows big
red candle followed by a green big
candle and that's your recovery. Okay,
that's what I'm paying attention to
really here. That's my take. Now, but
when I go to High Block Capital to have
a look at the at the liquidations and
I'm going to show you that in fact it
makes sense that there is quite a lot of
liquidity in this area here. Okay, let
me change to the time frame in the area
there. There is quite a lot of
liquidity. So potentially you could see
here the room for liquidity which would
be confirmed once price drops again
below the local resistance. That's where
you could open a short. Okay. And then
price could go towards this area. I
would probably say that price really
needs to fill this daily long week in
here in the daily time frame that it
goes from 85K to 80K. That's quite a
long week. So I would say that price
needs to come towards this area
potentially s the lows recover that's
when you open your uh your swing long to
the highs. All right pretty much the
same scenarios as I just showed you. Now
let me take you to have low capital.
Let's look at the liquidations. Why have
low capital? These are the liquidations
in high time frame. As you can see we
are taking the liquidations to the
upside. That means short liquidations.
Okay, it's kind of like a short squeeze
really because it's going up quite
aggressively hitting all the short
liquidations. You can see that 91K there
were a lot of liquidations that has been
taken and now we can see that there are
some more quite a lot more around 96K
exactly to be precise 95,800.
So why not? Why couldn't price continue
going up towards that area take that
liquidity that will be your liquidity
run and then turn around. All right,
that is my main scenario at the moment.
It will really surprise me which is
possible but it would really surprise me
if price goes up and recovers in a
straight line from here. It would really
surprise me to be honest. And if you
look at the liquidation levels, you can
see that right now there are um $12
billion worth of long liquidations. This
is the max liquidity setting. So the
amount I'm telling you is not real. It's
exaggerated, but it's what I've been
using for the past four, five years. So
it's what I'm used to. And usually right
now it's a 12 billion but usually it's a
quite strong signal. Once it's past 20
25 billions that's when is quite strong
signal of a reversal. And to be honest
right now we still have uh the double
really to go. So um not really important
just telling you that that there are
starting to be qual of cumulative long
liquidations but not enough to say that
it's a strong signal at all. All right
and also you can see here in the right
side of this chart you can see all these
peaks of of liquidity and these are
telling you the levels where there are
the most liquidation. So you can see
that all these peaks are showing you the
levels in the chart where there are the
most liquidations. And if you notice all
of them are to the downside. All right.
So you can see how this could be some
kind of liquidity run to the upside and
then drop price back to hit all these
liquidations. I think we're in a range
still to be honest. Um if price can
break above 100K then I'll tell you okay
things are definitely changing. I'm now
more open to the idea that you know we
are recovering that range well that
previous old range and you know 100k
should act as a very strong support and
price could start to go up from here
towards alltime highs but right now
it's still we are at 93k
okay so I see that scenario as less
likely to happen but that's it guys
quite a short video uh to update you
Thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon.